are you doing Jalen I'm good how are you
man I'm doing fine
now I asked this very uh I guess on pins
and needles because you or somebody who
who rates people for a living sometimes
how would you rate that a call of your
interception Jalen that's the best call
I've ever heard you did a good job now
you're just saying that you're just
saying that come on real sweet I
wouldn't just say that now you know me I
do know that I do know that I do know
you okay so that that does not suck is
what you're saying
okay I will take it how have you been
how's everything with you I've been good
man I can't complain guys bless me I'm
sorry I'm good okay what was it like
over your experience in London this past
weekend um it was a good experience
always loved going over there the
atmosphere on game days I mean crazy
it's packed everybody's in there they
might not you know be always room for
you but they got somebody that's how
Jersey on in there so it's a really good
atmosphere I love one over there okay no
obviously you didn't expect your team to
be three and five what could you tell us
about the season so far what do you
think ails this team as you hit a bye
week here Jalen yeah definitely not
ideal where we want to be going into our
final week but the good thing is that
our bye week comes right in the middle
of our season so we still have eight
games left to you know just turn it
around maybe hopefully win all eight of
these games I'm very optimistic about
excuse me what the future holds in
Jacksonville for the the rest of this
season and I'm excited we just have this
bar so we can you know reload get ready
for the second half of season so is it
something that from last season that's
lingering anything that you could put a
finger on here Jalen because you said
you know that there is something that
you just couldn't say but everybody knew
about what was going on with a team I'd
love to dive into that a little bit at
best year willing you know I just think
at the end of the day would have
down to it everybody has to you know
play harder we just have to figure out a
way at the end of the day it doesn't
matter how the winds come it doesn't
matter if it's ugly or pretty we have to
figure out how to get him how to stack
them up and what was the players only
meeting like a week ago for you Jalen oh
very open open and honest people got to
avoid some of their opinions play it was
it was very good very productive we came
closer as a team I believe doing that
but at the end of the day that's not
what's gonna win us games on Sunday we
still have to go out Sundays upon now
did you speak at that meeting did you
get up and talk yeah I did trust me I
know you're not gonna spill anything or
look I wouldn't obviously you know
you're not gonna talk about what goes on
in a player's only meeting but I'm just
wondering if you sometimes you know
obviously what you say comes across so
unvarnished sometimes to those who are
looking in and I'm wondering if you take
that into account when you do say
something to your teammates at all oh
you know I mean unapologetically so you
know when I when I speak I speak
especially once beginning with my
teammates I speak from the heart and I'm
speaking as a competitor and trying to
figure out the best way I can to help
this team win so that's really where it
came from and that's where everybody's
that's where it came from everybody came
out of love with what you've said
inside that meeting is what you're
saying so do you do you feel you're
you're in the media taken to task
unfairly sometimes I'm not sure I don't
already me personally I don't really
think too much of it I've never I mean
for people who don't know me personally
I've never I don't really take things
personally that you know when they say
about me or anything like that okay
because I did see what you said on the
you know on the uninterrupted platform
where you thoughts you know Belichick
shines off the median people find it
funny but if you
go anywhere in that direction that it's
something different do you feel that one
glad you watch that man oh I do
look I'd think that platforms fantastic
I love is that have you personally
connected with LeBron Jalen I have
before yeah I have before okay on this
subject itself he talked about what
would your conversation like with him I
mean every time that I have spoken to
him he's always giving me great advice
um you know it's just how professional
and he has been in his whole career and
how he's a Idol for not only basketball
players but for anybody in the sports
industry how it's handled itself
throughout his whole career is something
to admire and something to look up to
and try to emulate that as much as you
can I mean there was never be another
part but you saw to emulate the positive
that the positives that he's done in his
career right and so that's why you were
you were willing to hook up on his
platform to do something what you're
saying yeah okay so now are you but so
you do believe that that some people
treat you unfairly when they treat
Belichick differently I mean I mean you
take it I mean however but I mean
everybody's it is what it is everybody's
treated differently I mean it's just is
this part of the business but it's
alright it's nothing I don't think it's
I don't think it's up you know probably
more negative about it honestly it's
just how it is okay so what are you
doing with new Old Spice bomber
jaelyn words I never thought I'd ask you
but you know it's this is this is part
of the reason why you're on the show
today so what are you doing with these
guys
yeah always life spans it you know it's
like high school and even probably
before that Oh spices in all 32 NFL team
locker room so today we're just
introducing the new Old Spice foamer
it's instantly lathering body wash and
it's available at all Walmart's so okay
home and so you got the it's it's Old
Spice new Old Spice foamer that lather
is in a flash is what I'm reading right
now
okay so sir are you saying it's a flash
specialist what do you think uh yeah you
could say that it's a instant bone
specialist flash specialist now do you
do you bounce off people what you're
going to say what you plan to say I mean
is there anybody that you won't walk me
through when when you step up to a
microphone how you approach it
yeah I definitely do some sometimes uh
what most times I go over possibly
questions that may come up and what I'll
say back and sometimes it is straight
you know from the hair maybe okay
so prior to this did we did you bounce
anything off anybody you're just like
you know I'll call in a Rich's show and
we'll just go with the flow just trying
to figure that no I'm just going with
the flow with you man okay okay I
appreciate that okay should I take that
as a compliment done I think yeah I
think you should because I don't feel
like you're you're not uh you know one
of those guys I feel like I have to prep
for you're not trying to ask me trick
question no I'm not I just I just want
to ask what people I think want to know
you know what I'm saying and that that's
that's all I do
so if I had if I gave you a list of
people who do what I do for a living
would you go down and tell me if you
think they suck or not jaylen can we do
that I mean we could I don't I might not
know everybody by name okay more of a
facial recognition of God but okay good
try okay because I asked Elias Campbell
to do this on my behalf and I feel like
he didn't do that when he came on the
show yeah no I used to he's too nice
he's a gentle giant he's one of those
guys all right I was just kidding anyway
I don't really you know I'm not gonna go
without in that direction anyway I just
figured figured going that way all right
so what does your bye week look like as
I'll let you go Jalen yeah this about
week I mean we have to go in a few days
and get some things talk about some
things as a team so glad you ate a
little bit but after that everybody has
a little time off about four days or so
okay this reload
and kind of get our minds right and get
ready for the remaining later season
coming up I know a lot of guys will go
back home for a little time I got spend
time with family and um you know kind of
just like the other guys I'll be doing
the same thing okay what do you think of
the Dante Fowler trade to Los Angeles
Jalen yeah just hit it just hit my phone
fry before card let's do one my favorite
teammates as most people probably know
and I and I hate it but I mean it's part
of the business and I know that the rams
just got a got a good one so I mean I'm
happy for Don said he I guess he gets to
go somewhere and do what he does did it
surprise you that the team cost him up
oh yeah it does surprise me
um I mean yeah he does surprise me
I think it surprises a lot of our
teammates uh we were all big fans of
Dante you know around here he helps us a
lot
you know defensive linemen are a DVS
best friend a lot of times basically
pass rushers so yeah it sucks but like I
said it is part of the business and I
hope he goes out there and he enjoys uh
the team out there
you know does what he can do so um are
you tight with are you gonna go hang
with Tom Coughlin this week on your body
Jalen do you guys talk nah well I won't
see him during my ball week I want to
see him but uh are you what's your
relationship like with him it's good
good I mean anytime we you know we see
down the hallway we speak okay same
stuff each other I mean it's it's cool
okay very good
all right Jalen I want you on my show
more often you know I mean you're you're
you know you go on these all these Pro
Bowls and all that stuff first team Oh
Pro now I mean so just don't remember we
can make the Hat on for another man
don't forget about it just because just
because you're selling our own spice
farmer doesn't mean that's the only
reason why you come on here Jalen okay I
got you man I definitely keep it in mind
you know I'm a big fan no I
right back at you I just want to make
sure it's it that you're just not
holding it against me because I had one
row of a seat better than you at NFL
owners last year you did man you are you
have been rubbing it in my face just
make more Pro Bowls you know I'm saying
and then you know I have to figure out a
way that we can be right next to each
other at least now that I would do I
would I'll be your boy I'll be your boy
you know take care of yourself jaylen
you got @gl and Ramsey on Twitter from
the Jacksonville Jaguars here on the
show the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience